there was an interesting study run where
in the beginning of a brainstorming
session one group was asked to share
something they were proud of and another
group was asked to share an embarrassing
story so 100 vulnerability you're
sharing something you are actively
embarrassed by and when they measured
the productivity of the brainstorming
sessions after the fact the embarrassing
session the embarrassing story group
outperformed the proud of group the
magnitude of ideas increased but also
the diversity of ideas like the range
that they covered and so it's not even
that it feels good sometimes to share it
can affect productivity and outputs in
pretty powerful ways